jason gideon and david rossi represent
two major
eras in the history of the popular cbs
police procedural criminal minds
on one hand there are the first two
seasons of the show in which mandy
patinkins gideon reigned over a team of
relative fledgling agents in a
hard-boiled crime drama
potinkin would go on to famously and
abruptly abandon criminal minds in 2007
claiming its depiction of violence
against women to be too extreme and
demoralizing
just as pre-production on the third
season was to begin joe
montagne's rossi arrived in season three
as part of a surprise cast shake-up to
begin a trend that over the next 12
seasons
eventually relaxed into a less edgy and
grim production that began to focus more
on the behavioral analysis unit team as
a family dynamic
[Music]
it's a girl
the season 3 premiere aired in september
2007
and the show wrapped after 15 seasons in
february 2020
but the debate over the og cast member's
quality versus his replacement has never
really ceased
take a reddit thread from april 2020 for
example with a heading
rossi is better than gideon the general
concession within that thread and
others over the years generally agreed
with this stance to varying degrees and
qualifications
well that's a circumstantial snippet the
longtime popularity that rossi's
character enjoyed within the show
meant he was never replaced either and
that speaks for itself
as well when people talk about why they
like rossi
it's often in terms of what gideon
wasn't that is
funny warm and team-oriented comparing
them is almost an apples and oranges
argument
but the characters are joined by a
shared history as former co-workers and
founders of the bau
as an institution
yes definitely i'm definitely having fun
all that aside fans tend to appreciate
rossi because he definitely
is fun he hosts dinner parties at his
lovely home for his team members
offers his experience and wisdom with a
distinct kind of sassy humor
and is wise enough to know when to step
back and let the youths do what they do
best
rossi is much more flexible emotionally
and professionally than gideon
who hated cell phones and didn't always
get along with others on the team
especially when it was predicated on the
idea that gideon might be wrong
or unknowingly biased about something
all that adds up to rossi being a
character that is going to be naturally
more appealing to a larger audience
in general he's just better at being a
person interacting with other people
than gideon ever was
as rossi has explained as much himself
within the show
one responded and that rossi is better
reddit thread also made this excellent
point about why rossi is so popular
what if the roles were reversed like
rossi was in the first three seasons and
gideon were in the others
i think more of us would have liked
gideon because he would have had more
time to grow
and for us to like him since rossi has
been in more seasons he has grown as a
character a lot
and he has had bigger and more moments
to shine than gideon
in truth rossi's character changed over
his first couple seasons on criminal
minds at first
he was also pretty standoffish and more
than a little arrogant
often treating his coworkers as lesser
educated hooligans
he didn't evolve into the dead of the
bau overnight and that's easy to forget
over so many years and episodes
the things rossi has loved for his
gentleness humility
and real affection for all his younger
team members developed over time
and that was time which gideon as a
character was not granted
people have never really stopped missing
gideon's place in criminal minds
though a more substantial portion of
that interest isn't so much for gideon
himself
so much as the effect he had on his
former protege dr spencer reed
played by matthew grey gubler reed is a
fan favorite
and the loss of gideon in his life
defined his character in ebbs and flows
over the rest of the entire series
there is even some hope that potenkin
might show up for the series finale
despite having ghosted on the series
over a decade earlier
that of course never came to be all that
aside gideon does have his fans
particularly when it comes to the
distinct skills
knowledge and characterization he
brought to the table these preferences
of course can be defined mostly by taste
and gideon's strengths were in fact a
particular flavor that criminal
minds let slip away over time as the
show evolved
changed and found its own stride that's
not a value judgment it's simply what
happens
and opinions vary in the end it really
depends on if you watched criminal minds
as a semi-faithful examination of a real
law enforcement technique
or if you showed up to watch the bau and
friends killer hour
we're gonna start at the beginning eat
what you cook i'll supervise
but we're gonna do this all together
just like a family check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite tv characters are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you